these penguins are starving to death
they're looking for krill small shrimps
which need ice in order to survive but
the ice pack is melting the Antarctic
has warmed up by three degrees over the
past 50 years far too much the 2015
Paris agreement on climate cop21 set a
maximum limit of two degrees an
agreement that must now be enforced and
that's the objective of cop 22 thats
just begun in Marrakech a delegation
from the European Parliament was there
in Dallas we have agreed on a global
deal for climate protection now it has
to be implemented and there are a lot of
rules that have to be agreed so we need
a rule book at the heart of the
discussion in Marrakech is how to
finance the Paris agreement and in
particular how to support developing
countries trento me dr de diego on jaan
lo que verano Costa to ear y lavando el
campamento p Montego pesos tener a queef
ICP poder que non potrà nos 0 parts in
cuidando pack a dog a node Allah primo
estante peruana encanto al nov
technology spend a ready fue para un
pianeta pew corrido y seguramente
poussin of these financial commitments
depend in part on the politics of the
new American president who has pledged
to leave the Paris agreement
even if John Kerry the Acting Secretary
of State has reassured the international
community that the United States remains
committed to fighting climate change
you